This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. In the 1939 movie, The Wizard of Oz, one of the central characters is the cowardly line. He cuts a figure that is recognizable to us all. He longs to be brave, but when his courage is tested, he shrinks in fear. Look at that. Look at that. I want to go home. The cowardly lion eventually discovers his true nature. When he is given a medal to honor his courage,
it helps him see that he is, in fact, a lion, that he was brave all along. The moral of the story is clear. The lion always had the capacity to be brave. He just didn't know it. The Wizard of Oz is a work of fiction, but every day we see the cowardly lion's dilemma entails from real life. situations where people are called upon to be brave.
Sometimes they rise to the occasion, but many fail to do so, often with disastrous consequences. Fear, of course, is not always a bad thing. Evolutionary biologists find that circuits in the brain that govern the fear response are ancient, but fear can keep us from living our best lives, reaching for our dreams, and upholding our values. This week on Hidden Brain
and in a companion episode on Hidden Brain Plus, how to discover our inner lion. into a burning building or standing up to an armed enemy. Other times it involves speaking up when everyone else stays silent or stepping forward when your instinct is to shrink back. Today, we look at those defining moments when life calls on us to be brave when the choice is between cowardice and courage. Ranjay Gullati is a behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School.
He studies how people behave under conditions of great risk. He has thought a lot about the next. nature of courage. Ranjay, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. It's a pleasure to be here today. Ranjay, you've looked into the story of a high school language teacher in China. On the afternoon of May 12, 2008, he was in his classroom conducting a lesson. Tell me who he was and what happened next?
Fanme Zong was a teacher and he was in the middle of his class talking about an esoteric 18th century literary Chinese scholar when the building started to shake. You know, it got a little uncomfortable, but then the tremor turned into a full-blown earthquake where now everything was shaking. And van Meizong didn't hesitate. He ran. He opened the door and he ran out of the building. He was the first one out of the building, actually. And he got to the main ground and in fact the boundary wall around the ground starts to collapse also wow and the students eventually also come out and he asked his students where were you why didn't you come out and they asked him where were you we got so scared we actually hid under the table and we were hiding
under our desks waiting for direction on what to do their question was you're our teacher you should have been there to help us get out of there rather than run out of there first and run out of there first. And Fanbizond had no remorse whatsoever and he said
look when it comes to my own physical safety I am a coward and so I needed to save myself first and that was how he completely rationalized his response. So eventually the earthquake resulted in nearly 90,000 people reported or presumed dead. Many children died across the region when school buildings crumbled on top of them.
As news reports got out about this teacher's behavior, what was the public reaction, Ranjay? The public's reaction was one of outrage. At one point, he was considered the most hated man in China. They had derogatory nicknames for him, like a running fan. And so he then comes out and speaks and tries to defend and justify his own action. And this has an even bigger backlash on him. As a society, we really can't stand cowards.
cowardice is one of the most derogatory terms you can use to label somebody and that was the label pinned on fan he lost his job and it didn't end for several months after you tell another story about a life-threatening emergency this one occurred in 23 on the subway in New York City, a man named Adam Klotz was riding the train when he saw something happening in the subway car. What did he observe and what did he do, Ranj? So Adam Klotz is a meteorologist. He's on his way to work and he sees some young kids harassing an older gentleman. And, you know, as a good Samaritan and a good citizen, he chooses
to intervene. Nobody else is doing anything. And he just asked them to stop doing what they were doing. And that then leads them to redirect attention to him. He then tries to avoid confrontation by going to another car. They follow him. And at some point they start to beat him up rather viciously. And nobody else comes to his defense. And that to him was the shocker that nobody else stood up for him
the way he had for the older gentleman. So here we see examples of both courage and cowardice in a single subway car. Ranjay, I understand that you yourself once saw this juxtaposition of courage and cowardice in your own life. You were a teenager living in India with your mother. She had started a successful business. Set the scene for me and tell me what happened. So my mother was a successful fashion designer.
She had a business and she bought herself a piece of farmland outside New Delhi where she was going to have a farmhouse for the weekend getaway. This land turned out to become very valuable. A developer was chasing her to buy it. She said, I don't want it. I don't want to sell. I don't want the money. I want to keep my land.
So one day I'm home on a weekend and this gentleman comes to the gate and he asked to see my mom and he's from the developer. I said, no, she's not going to meet you. and he said, listen, tell her, this is the last time we'll ever bother her. She says, okay, fine, send him in. Just a regular gentleman wearing a blazer comes in, sits down, across from my mother, where she's sitting on her sofa. And he puts in front of on the table a blank check, signed.
And a piece of paper and says, ma'am, you enter the amount. Whatever you want. We just want to buy this from you. She says, no, I really don't want to sell. I'm sorry, here's your check back. There's no amount for which I want to sell this land. gets my belligerent she pushes back and says
no I'm not selling he finally says ma'am I can't leave without your signature today I have to get your signature so she says well I'm sorry you're not going to at this point he pulls his blazer back and he reveals he has a gun tucked in his waist
I'm standing at the door watching this whole thing unfold I see the gun too in my mind I'm doing my cost benefit you know I'm looking at the timing should I wait should I wait Should I let him reach for the gun? Maybe it's a bluff.
Should I go call the guard at the gate? I'm working this out in my head. My mother doesn't hesitate at all. She gets her from our sofa, walks across the table, and slaps him right across the face. He doesn't even see it coming. And then she says, how dare you? How dare you come into my house
and try to bully me and try to tell me to give you my land and you're going to threaten me with a gun? Get out of here. He doesn't see it coming. He scampers away forgetting his checkbook. I have to run after him to give him his checkbook. And I then asked my mom, I said, Mom, didn't you see he had a gun?
She says, yes. I said, what are you scared? She said, yes. So what? When you thought about your own behavior in that moment, Ranjay, I mean, it's perfectly understandable why you would freeze in that moment. But when you reflected back on yourself, did you see some deeper character trait that prompted you not to act in that moment?
I think, you know, maybe there was something in myself, when I was a naturally hesitant. I would always deliberate before action. And sometimes my deliberations would take longer than normal. And whereas my mother was a very, you know, being a self-made businesswoman, she was a very confident person. And I think in her mind, she had a sense of herself as somebody who had a can-do mindset like many entrepreneurs do.
and as a woman growing up in that time in India where it was a very paternalistic system, she was not easy to be pushed around and she was often being pushed around by a very male-dominated society and system. So my own hesitation, I think, was a thoughtful cost-benefit, let's do the risk-adjusted returns, if I may say, so, you know, I'm doing my risk analysis,
scenario planning, working out of the scenarios, in my head, which I thought was okay. I mean, that's what I'm supposed to do. But it was a learning moment. It was a, it was a learning moment from me. In the aftermath of this, did you feel like a coward? Absolutely. I did. You know, again, as, even though I was only 14 years, old, you know, as her son, I felt like it was my duty and responsibility to be the one to have protected her versus her having to do it for herself. But it also made me realize very quickly that fear can paralyze you and that you have to make a choice sometimes. And she didn't give
me a long lecture afterwards. She just said, just because you're scared doesn't mean you do nothing. And that line kind of has always stayed with me. Just because you're scared doesn't mean you do nothing. Life frequently presents us with moments that require a fateful choice. Will we hang back in a state of fear and cowardice? Or will we plunge ahead into brave and courageous action? When we come back, the attitude. and practices that separate the timid from the bold.
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Ranjee Gulati is a behavior. behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School. He has seen examples of courage and cowardice in his own life and in stories drawn from the news. When he sees stories of people acting courageously,
he asks himself, what allowed these people to live up to their values, to stand up for what's right? Ranjay, a few years ago, a question started to nag at you, and you decided to investigate it scientifically. What was this question? The question really was, how do people operate in the face of uncertainty? Risk is where you have tools to assess, quantify, even mitigate it.
Uncertainty is like a thick fog, no clear odds, no fool-truth strategies. It turns out that most of us are able to deal with risk, tackle risk. We make money off of risk in the entire field of finance. Uncertainty actually activates the amygdala and it triggers what is considered a survival emotion, fear. It moves quickly and it paralyzes us. So people say fight or flight. It's actually fight, flight or freeze. And fight is the rarest of all responses. It's mostly flight or freeze. I have no scientific basis for this, but I would like to hypothesize that most of us are descendants of cowards. Our ancestors, the ones who made it, ran for cover. The ones who ran for
Then after danger didn't quite make it. Now, at the same time, humankind has only progressed by virtue of those feud, the daring feud, the right brothers risking their lives to say, I'm going to give it to try, Madam Curie, others who personally took risk also for themselves, whether it was Mahatma Gandhi, Martin Luther King, Nelson Mandela, all these people put themselves at risk. we are all the beneficiaries of those bold actions. Can you talk about the idea that from ancient times, people have puzzled over why some of us are braver than others, and one school of thought has held that bravery is just something that is innate in some people. Some people just happen to be brave. this is a real question
because as I looked at the biographies of some of these people, you know, you read Mahatma Gandhi, he was not always a courageous person. Very early in his life, he was trying to be a barrister. He was living in England. He wanted to be more English than the English themselves.
Right? And then he had a moment of realization that changed things for him. He was horrible public speaker. He was absolutely frightened of speaking in public. And here you have somebody who then speaks to millions of people. So you start to see that some of these people actually cultivate courage.
And you discover that courage is a choice. It's a choice you make. And it's a choice you make in the face of fear. It forces you to become acquainted with the discomfort we feel when we are scared. Let's examine some of the things that courageous people do. You say that they construct the right kind of narrative What are these narratives and why are they important, Renji? So, Max Weber, a famous sociologist in the last century,
talked about how human behavior can either be rational, which is looking at all options and trying to evaluate those choices, or interpretive. Interpretive is where you're looking at everything through a lens of meaning, understanding. What does it mean for me? and what is the meaning of the situation. So this narrative is how we construct a story about the situation.
What's going on here? Is it personally meaningful to me? And a story we construct of ourselves in that situation. And most times this interpretive calculus takes us to freeze or flight. But sometimes we feel compelled. I have to do something. this situation is the moment where if I don't do it, I can't live with myself. One of the stories that you say can support our efforts to be courageous is what you call a moral quest.
Talk about this idea. You've mentioned Mahatma Gandhi, you've mentioned Nelson Mandela, Martin Luther King Jr. All of them, it would seem, were not just on a political journey, but on a moral journey of some kind. I think most of us inside ourselves want to be great at something. I want to be somebody.
I want to be known for something. And when you encounter something that you really buy into as a morally potent idea, it elevates our thought. We feel a sense of responsibility. I need to do something. thing. In a previous project I did, I wrote a book called Deep Purpose in which I looked at even
startups. They start not only with an idea. They usually start with an ideal. We want to change the way this thing gets done. We're going to transform the way these customers have to do this. We're going to completely redo the way this is done. And that energizes people in these small companies. In fact, when the companies get big, they lose it. And then they're like, oh, my God, we lost our soul. I remember speaking many years ago with Scott Atron. He studies extremist groups and violent movements and so forth. But one of the things he looks at is this idea that, you know, all of us are motivated, of course, by, you know, costs and benefits. We are making cost-benefit calculations as we go through life. But he talks about the set of beliefs that we can
have, which he called sacred values. And sacred values are things that in some ways are not amenable to cost-benefit calculations. If someone were to say, you know, how much money would you be willing to accept in exchange for your child's life? You would say no amount of money is going to be worth it because my child's life is not connected to the realm of transaction of buying and selling, that there's no amount that you could give me that would allow me to betray my country or to betray my family. In some ways, I think that's what you're talking about when you talk about having a moral quest. In some ways, it moves the conversation from a cost-benefit calculation to something that in some ways is beyond it. Absolutely. But I don't want to make the distinction
so clean. I think we're doing cost-benefit while we are also doing this other factor that is compelling us to take action. So it's usually the intersection of the two, right? I don't know my mother's no longer here, but I'm not sure if the guy had already pointed the gun and had his finger on the trigger that she would have tried to work around him, right? I would imagine that in her mind, she must have decided that if I had a moment, it's now or never. And as she explained later, she says, he was determined to get my signature. He had said clearly, his intention was, I'm not leaving here without your signature. So his next move would have been to actually pull that gun out. right he had just shown it to her so in some ways it was a brilliant preemptive move so these ideas
kind of intersect where there is a utilitarian thought process and then there is a emotional thought process and that are coming together and hopefully they intersect or sometimes what I found is the emotional trumps utilitarian. You're like, I'm going to do this no matter what. I don't care. That's where it goes to another whole different level. Years ago, Ranjay, you had a student at Harvard Business School who went on to work at Facebook. The rest of the world was introduced.
to this former student of yours in October 2021 when she testified before a congressional subcommittee. Here's a bit of what she said. My name is Francis Howgan. I used to work at Facebook. I joined Facebook because I think Facebook has the potential to bring out the best in us. But I'm here today because I believe Facebook's products harm children, stoke division, and weaken our democracy. The company's leadership knows how to make Facebook and Instagram saver, but won't make the necessary changes because they have put their astronomical profits before people. So Runji, it must have taken considerable courage for Francis Hogan to stand up to a behemoth like Facebook. She wasn't just walking away from a job. She was walking
away from her career, from coworkers, from friends. You say that she embedded her actions in a moral quest? Absolutely. I think, you know, for her having seen firsthand, one of her own friends getting radicalized by content on Facebook, she had felt it and seen it up front. It was not an abstraction anymore. And I think that brought her to a point where she felt she had to do something, that doing nothing was not an option. We had this notion of the lone hero myth in courage. She didn't do it alone. She pondered it for several months and only when she had a support squad who were really able to nudge her forward was she finally willing to go all the way
so courage is not a solo sport it takes a village and so you have to curate the right kind of support she got emotional support from her parents and friends she got informational or knowledge support from a law firm that specialized in helping whistleblowers
she got resource support from news media that was going to cover her story and she got feedback support from a friend of hers who was actually an ordained priest with whom she would have candid conversations would tell her what she was doing or not doing and whether it felt right or not.
So, you know, there were this multitude of support that along with her own sense of morality that brought her to a point where she felt she had to do something. And in some ways, I think I'm seeing the same scaffolding in many of the stories that you have told me around Jays. So if you think about Gandhi or King or Mandela, they also in some ways combined, you know, a deep moral fervor with real strategy and real tactical, you know, sophistication. And Francis Hauken did the same thing.
I mean, she had a moral fervor. She believed what she was doing was right. But as you say, she in some ways got her legs under her before she decided to make her move. Absolutely. And the moral fervor doesn't always involve some higher order purpose. it can. In startups, you know, you can see them saying, I want to transform the way this market works. I'm going to change the way this gets done. And so that fervor can take the form of transforming society, transforming a market, transforming others' lives. In some way, and I think
what you discover is people in these moments who are drawn to these higher order or purposeful endeavors. Instead of being engaged in the project, they are actually inspired by it. They are energized in a very different way, which is why the behavior you see in small, fast-growth startups of employees is not what you see when those same companies hit 500,000, 2,000 employees. You see a decline and change in people's motivation and how they show up. So cultivating courage might start with examining the stories we tell ourselves about our capacities, but we also need to gather information about what's out there, the scary situation that requires our bravery. You talk about the idea of sense-making.
What is sense-making here in this context, Ranji? So what I discovered was once you've got the kind of the moral fervor and the identity and meaning to move you into wanting, to do something, people resource themselves in a variety of way. They have a set of a toolkit and tactics they absorb. One of the first ones I discovered was sense making. Sense making is a classic term used by a very famous organizational theaters from Michigan named Carl Weik. And Carl Weik looked at firefighters.
When a firefighter goes into a building, they don't know. There's a tremendous amount of uncertainty. How fast is the fire happening? How combustible is it? Are there other kind of combustible liquids in the building? Are there people in the building who need to be saved? How much time do I have before I need to make a hasty exit? All this is going on.
Now, if you're going to do your risk-adjusting your calculation over here, you're never going to go into the building. They don't have that option. So they go into the building with an initial hypothesis. They've seen the building, the structure. They know how long the fire has been going on. They have a guess as to point. of origin, entry, looking around cues, what's here, what's there, updating your theory, taking
some more steps. Should I be going upstairs to look for people, should I go into the basement, should I look for point of origin? What should I be doing next? So it's a story of kind of tippy-toeing your way into the fog, what is called acting your way into knowing. Rather than knowing before acting, sometimes you have to act your way into knowing. You say that a masterful example of acting your way into knowing took place in the wake of the major tsunami that hit Japan in 2011. Tell me that story. What happened there that in some ways exemplifies this idea? So everybody knows about the Fukushima Daiichi plant, which had a melt-up.
Just eight miles away was another plant complex called the Da'ini plant. This too was damaged equally badly. Both of them had a boundary wall of 20 feet high, and the tsunami had crossed 55 feet of water, which had submerged the nuclear reactors, the cooling systems, and everything else. And all these people, the 300-odd employees, had raced into the emergency response center where they were trying to understand what's going on. A power plant like that works off of gauges, sensors and gauges, all blanked. And in there is the plant manager, Masuda.
Mr. Masuda says, what are we going to do? Headquarters says, we don't know. They don't know. This is okay. He got five volunteers to go outside. and do a wrecky tour to find out how bad are things. So they go out and they find out, well, the power supply to the cooling system is gone. There's no other immediate source of power we can get.
So we need to get power back somehow into our systems or else the meltdown is guaranteed. Back. Taking stock. Another group, let's send you out to different sources of power to see, is there any place we can find power? let's send people out to find out about access to cables power cables we'll need cables to create a little extension cord if I may say so now you're trying to grapple with the situation then you start you get the cable you find the power source and you then say let's take it to the nearest reactor to where the power source is they start to do that when they discover
another reactor has suddenly the temperatures rising much faster they call GE and say all these reactors were the same model, why is this one heating up much faster? They come back and say, you know, actually this was a slightly older model. It has the same numbering on it, but it's a slightly older version. That's why it's probably heating up faster. So they said, okay, forget taking the power to that first reactor. Let's bring it straight to this other one because this one is heating up too fast. So you know,
you're going in, improvising, adjusting, and learning by doing. And they successfully avoided catastrophe here. You talk about the importance, Ranjay, of trying to convert uncertainty to risk. And you say that one person who pulled this off in 1974, was a man named Philippe Petit. What did he do? He's a tightrope walker, a daredevil, if you may say so.
And, you know, at that time, he walked between the World Trade Center buildings. Subsequently, he's done a walk over the Grand Canyon and several other such feats. So in some extensive writing by him, he actually describes it. He says, people describe me as a daredevil. I don't see myself that way.
I am very, very methodical, very calculating, very careful. So what you are seeing as completely reckless, to my mind, is methodical, thought-out activity. He spent almost 11 years collecting data on wind patterns and other aberrations that can happen over the Grand Canyon before he did that walk. So what you see as kind of reckless behavior is actually. very, very well thought out. In other words, it's very tightly controlled. At one point, Philip says, if I think I'm a hero who is invincible,
I will pay for it with my life. So in other words, he understands that if he actually goes outside the realm of what he has tightly prepared for, if he goes off script, if you will, that's exactly when very bad things happen. Yeah. Now, take another example,
which is of heroic behavior, is Tom Cruz, who does most of his own stunts. In fact, he drove a motorcycle off of a cliff and then parachuted into the valley and he did it six times till he got it right. And when asked, you know, like, Tom, aren't you scared doing this? And he says two things. One is, he says, yes, I'm afraid,
but you know, I'm okay and comfortable with being afraid. That's the first thing. So he's tamed and managed his own fear. But at the same time, you should see the entire team that is supporting this effort, right? How they've trained up for this, how they've simulated and planned for this. This is not just Tom finding a random cliff and saying, let's just race off the cliff. So the massive amounts of preparation that have gone in, probably much more than if they'd used a backup stunt artist. So that's where people are taking what looks like an uncertain story.
turning it into risk and then learning to manage that risk. In order to become brave, we need to tell inspiring stories about ourselves and our journeys. We also need to learn about the nature of the frightening or daunting challenges we face and to deliberately test our abilities
to deal with them. When we come back, the role of the psychological factor known as self-efficacy. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you had times in your life when you found yourself unable to do the brave thing, when you shrank back from a challenge and fail to live up to your values?
Or can you think of a moment when you were frightened but somehow managed to be brave. If you have a personal story you'd be willing to share with the hidden brain audience or a question or comment about this episode about the science of bravery, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo. Two or three minutes is plenty. Then email the file to us at feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, frightened. Again, that's feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. At a commencement addressed some years ago, the writer
and civil rights activist Maya Angelou said, you can be kind and true and fair and generous and just, and even merciful, occasionally. But to be that thing, time after time, you have to really have courage.
Ranjay Gulladi is a behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School. He is the author of How to Be bold. the surprising science of everyday courage. Ranjay, in your studies of courageous people, you found that they deliberately cultivate a capacity known as self-efficacy. What is self-efficacy,
and how does it help people become braver? So self-efficacy, the construct, was first studied by a famous Stanford psychologist, Albert Bandura, who was trying to convince people who are fearful of snakes to hold a corn snake. and what is interesting is
in that study and several others that he did he makes a very important distinction between the domain-specific efficacy that you may have and then a generalized efficacy that you may have. Domain-specific is, I am the master of my craft. I know my task, I'll do it, I'll get it done. Generalized efficacy is this general notion of I can do it. I got it.
bring it on captain sullenberger landing a plane on the hudson river you know sure he was a seasoned veteran 40 year pilot fighter pilot before that but he had never really trained simulated landing on a river but you know when he was interviewed by katie kurek who asked him like look you know what do you need to do he said oh yeah i knew the textbook this this this this this this he says but there was still a big if and he looked at it and he says i knew i could do it that I knew I could do it. That kind of confidence, if I may call it that, which is this generalized can-do spirit,
that becomes the kernel of what allows us to then ultimately take bold action even in the face of uncertainty. I mean, in some ways, we heard this in the story you told about your mother. I mean, she had a domain-specific self-efficacy. She was a designer. She must have been very good at her craft. But clearly, she also had a higher-level sense of self-efficacy because she said, even when I'm confronting somebody who shows up at my house with a gun,
I know that I'll be able to handle the situation. I think most entrepreneurs, I shouldn't say most, but many entrepreneurs have that general sensibility because, you know, things are changing so fast around them and the curve balls coming at them are so many from so many directions by necessity but you're right i think in if i look at her from afar you know her life was always one of the i got it nothing would kind of phase her how do we cultivate that that's the question now and what is the answer to that question because again i think people might say some people just have it some people don't but i think your theory is that
in fact, this is something that can be grown, can be cultivated. Look, it starts with domain-specific efficacy, first of all. You have to be the master of your craft. You have to really understand your craft in a way that nobody else does. It should be deeply internalized into who you are. Then when you go beyond that, I find you can take yourself so far, but sometimes you need external validation. what do coaches do so well for teams you know what do they do they help the player believe in themselves
that self-belief i know you got it and and i think that becomes part of the story so you're looking for external sources of validation as well and then when you're playing for somebody else when you're doing it for something bigger than yourself that further boosts up your confidence that I got it, I can do it. This self-belief sometimes comes from within and sometimes comes from an externalized source who also believes in you. A very dramatic example of how domain-specific self-efficacy
can lead to generalize self-efficacy is in the story of the terrorist attack on the Taj Mahal Palace Hotel in Mumbai, India in 2008. What happened that day, Ranja, and how did employees at the hotel respond? So several terrorists found their way into the hotel and laid a siege on the hotel for the next 60 hours. They were marauding around the hotel, they were lighting fires, they were shooting guests, they were shooting employees,
basically trying to wreak havoc as much as they could. and meanwhile there was no way for the police and commanders to even go in they didn't know what to do there was a bit of a mess over there and what is interesting is none of the employees ran away even the in fact the hotel operators whose cubicles were right behind the front desk evacuated soon after the attacks came back in because they realized all the guests stuck in their rooms were calling and trying to get help. And so they all went back into the hotel. But the story I think best exemplifies this is Malika Jaggat, 24 years old. She's been assigned an event to welcome the new CEO of Global Unilever, Paul Polman. And there is a farewell for the departing
CEO. And the global leadership of Unilever is there, including the Indian leadership as well. And she's in charge of this event. And now you have the siege in the hotel. And the siege in the hotel. She locks the doors, tells everybody things are not okay, makes them lie down on the floor and asks them to stay quiet. This goes on the whole night. Right? And she's in charge. As she explained later, she was the youngest in the room, actually.
But she was in charge. And there's no script for this, right? She's now working way beyond script. All she knows, her script is take care of the guests. And the purpose statement in the Taj's guest is God. Adhisi Deva, which means guest is God. And that's all she can think of. And then early hours on the morning, there's a fire lit outside in the hallway.
So now smoke is coming into this conference in this big room. And they have to get out or they're going to die. So she instructs two of her staffers to try to break the windows, which are big, thick windows. They use chairs and manage to break one of the windows. They see the general manager down there They wave to him He sees them He sees the smoke coming out of the room
He directs the firefighters there A ladder is put Malika makes everybody All the guests get out first She's the last one off Out of the room Now you ask yourself What training did she have
You know To carry her through this moment And she said you know, in an interview afterwards, she said, I was just doing my job. So, Ranjay, we've been talking about very rational and deliberate approaches to cultivate courage. But you also write about a different path to becoming braver, and that is calling upon our faith.
What have you discovered about the link between courage and faith? So human beings for thousands of years have had to deal with uncertainty. You know, weather uncertainty, you know, geopolitical uncertainty. And for the longest time, we have believed in a higher power. A higher source. Something bigger than us is there to take care of me.
Now, I don't want to debate right now. whether there is a force or not, we can have a long discussion about that. But at the venom, it definitely calms us down, knowing that there is a higher power of force there for me. In some ways, I would call it outwitting our fear
or taming our fear. Because knowing that I'm supported by this higher force gives me the comfort, the confidence, the belief that, you know what, it looks dangerous, it looks scary, but I know something bigger than me has my back. And people manifest this in many different ways.
You write about a firefighter named Joe Ibarra and the way he used his faith to face a terrifying situation with great courage. Tell me his story. So here's a firefighter who is a firefighter who is, in Idaho fighting a forest fire. And on day one, the fire looks pretty okay, tame and so forth, and they're trying to kind of contain it and figure it out. And then the next day, the fire explodes. It gets so, so dangerous and so bad. His supervisor announces that they, this is out of control, we need to go into our fire tents. And so here he is, he has a radio, he has his
fire tent, and he has a rosary. And he's holding on to this rosary because he's being believes that if he has the rosary, he'll be protected. And he's praying. And magically, just soon after, a helicopter comes and dumps a bunch of water on them and douses the fire. And in his mind, this was just another manifestation of this higher power that was there for him.
In his mind, he believes firmly that with this rosary, he'll always be safe. So you told me at the start of our conversation, Ranji, that you yourself have always been a very cautious person, a very deliberate person, you think about the risks before you embark on something. Have you, after all of this study about the science of bravery, have you tried to take it upon yourself to become a braver person? You know, I think that moment with my mother probably haunted me more than I would like
to admit. But I actually, after, soon after, I actually decided I was going to try and put myself in situations that made me a little uncomfortable. So, very early, when I came to the U.S., I went to flight school to learn how to fly a plane. I never told my parents about that. But off I went to fly. And, you know, it was okay, as long as I had an instructor next to me, you know, and you're okay flying.
And, you know, it's, and he showed us that you can glide the plane if the engine shuts off. And so intellectually, you kind of got it. But the big moment for a personal training is when you go solo, your first solo flight. That was a long time ago. It was 1985. I still remember my solo flight because I had in my head decided that I was going to imagine that Jerry, my instructor, was sitting next to me. And the entire flight, I was in conversation with Jerry. You know, Jerry props are up, you know, taking off, you know, calling ground control.
I'm talking to Jerry and here I was talking my way through the flight. I needed to comfort myself. I came to realize, you know, that fear is natural. You know, I had gotten over the shame of fear. That was very important. That for me, the first step was the shame I felt when I felt scared. I needed to overcome that part. Now I overcome the shame.
Now I had to figure out how to tame my fear. And I'm trying to find a way to tame my fear. And then I have to take it to the next level. I'm going to act in spite of my fear. You can never eliminate fear. I can't tame it to zero. So I had to cross that chasm from shame to tame to really transcend. And that was my first for real.
I did another thing as well. I also then realized that I was not too comfortable in deep water. I think watching the movie Jaws really did me in. So I learned how to windsurf. And off I went to learn how to windsurf. And I spent several summers windsurfing. And again, not the most comfortable thing for me when I first started it. But I was determined to show myself.
It wasn't to show my mother. My mother didn't even know all most of these things were happening. But I was determined to show myself that I could do it. As you have listened to this episode, you might be thinking of people in your life who could use a dose of bravery. Do you have a fearful child or a fearful parent? a colleague who always worries about worst-case scenarios? Would you like to help them discover their inner lion? In our companion story to this episode,
available exclusively to subscribers to Hidden Brain Plus, we explore how we can help others become more courageous. If you're a subscriber, that episode is available right now. It's titled How to Help Others Be Brave. If you're not yet a subscriber, please visit support.hiddenbrain.org or Apple.com slash hidden brain. You'll instantly have access to all our subscriber-only content, including past episodes. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.com slash hidden brain.
Ranjay Kulari is a behavioral scientist at Harvard Business School. He's the author of How to Be Bold, the surprising science of everyday courage. Ranjay, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar. It's been a pleasure to be with you today. If you have a question or a personal story about courage that you'd be willing to share with a hidden brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo. Two or three minutes is plenty. Then email the file to us.
at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, frightened. Again, that's Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer.
I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Next week in our U2.0 series, how to get going again when you're stuck in a rut. In any pursuit, it doesn't really matter what you're doing, but trying multiple approaches, experimenting, figuring out whether the dominant approach is the right one or whether you should try something a bit different is the way forward. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon.
Thank you. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.